welcome to this video playing Jimmy the
saint yeah one guy we have bets kya one
now I remembered I don't have any good
somehow not any good memories connected
to this one out of four can't get the
guy surname in them no Egypt right yep
so them come on I want to close this
bloody window the Queens gambit declined
with Bishop f4 let's six or so somewhat
uncommon you know he has this isolated
Queen porn position d 4 is not possible
because of my day for in this position
and this is why it's plan I could have
maybe played rook see one first maybe a
bit more precise look see one is more
precisely ok but nothing nothing
terrible
okay um night to be five may be here how
do i play this position you can also
take at night a for now maybe do this
prep move a 3 before is also always
fitting into this position okay so if I
start with this and then night a 4 it's
not even going for that ok now this
should be slightly better for wider just
a comfortable position maybe rook c8
here mmm maybe you can play whoopsie aid
well like it's still fairly solid I mean
this is Wow
and that's surprising ok I'm going to
going to take him rooks is six I can
play this intermediate move right i'm
not sure if i want i can i can take on
d4 as well ok and take him ok take with
the queen is that something mm-hmm i can
always go to e 3 cap I don't understand
yet the point of all this yeah well here
black is just going into a rose end game
against the bishops rooks d1 or I can
also just take a seven there is no no
big drawback that I can see
here's a discovery on the bishop but I
wear away exactly Queenie for the
special pair 3
I really don't see any any sort of
compensation 95 yeah maybe 95
yeah I want to make sure not to a use up
maybe maybe just here use up a ton of
time to get into some big-time pressure
at the end I can take the six queen bee
oneness look see one so no problem with
that quindi one look even I mean check
ok so Brooke t2 i can take c6 with the
temple he's got this this problem with
this background as well ok so maybe just
drew a one get it hit be some behind the
past porn i can i can go here and then
push the pawn
ok before and I have rookie to if you
place rook the eighth i go rookie too ok
this one but this here is not it's not
threatening to enter on e2 just here
maybe to gather up t 7n
this is this is threatening v5t is tied
to the f porn
that's difficult for him to two lb 50
why not be five I can just take now yeah
and now advance with the King and King
can just go all the way to d6 c7 or now
this is in fact the easiest yes I'm so
that I have fun so that i have looked d6
if you give the check and c 7 is coming
with a check so now this looked like a
good end game Jack didn't I don't think
I allowed anything anything great iam um
let's think about it for a moment it's
easiest if I gold c7 King be 70 promote
would be 6 yeah i get i get to the pawns
first him still I can just go here and
play group III that's that's even easier
check
black resigns oh it was a bit strange I
and I wasn't sure what what D for was
why he played that maybe it was possible
that the way it it it turned out in the
game I was really just a pawn up for for
nothing for nothing in particular I
thought he could maybe just play rook c8
yeah okay I can't do this I can do this
of course yeah that is that gives white
a small reg with the bishops you have it
mighty phone is not really it's just
keeping keeping the pawn and I can
really just take it yeah I think I I
kept I kept edge here of course should
not play Queen you wanna take this
exchanges right into a lost endgame this
is really lost for black with the a pawn
in on marching you know maybe I had
something something more decisive but
this is just is just wrong because the
rook is attacking the two weaknesses and
keeps the keeps both pieces in a way
tight then cannot move any of his pieces
ok this is really running into be five
but it's very difficult to do anything
here if you consider let's say here I
can do something like this just improve
further and at some point I can't even
go in FY f5 and there are new weaknesses
to come so it's a it's a very one-sided
endgame the porn the better structure
and the very active rook that attacks
the weakness system ok thanks for
watching